please so what a crowd we gotta but we
have such a big show there's so much
news to get you okay shut up
look we got to get to the news there's
some people out there watching I know
what you think it's just us but but and
here there's some finally good news
finally America is retaliating they did
this today against Russia for real that
where it hurts with the money with the
money we put sanctions put sanctions on
the biggest Russian oligarchs but you
know what how come when it's a rich
creep in Russia they're an oligarch but
in America you're just a visionary you
founded Facebook you know oh the tech
company did you see what happened at
YouTube this week I mean yes you are a
woman who was very disgruntled about how
YouTube was handling her videos when in
there with a gun fortunately nobody was
killed but it was weird and before she
started shooting there they everybody
had to watch an ahead
[Applause]
but no the great news everybody is that
Donald Trump finally is unfettered you
know he fired like all of his original
cabinet so he's got some great new ideas
of his own yeah he's just riffing now
like this week troops at the border
great yeah we're putting National Guard
troops at the border
even though border arrests from Mexico
or at their lowest level since 1971
someone needs to tell him to have a
Mexican standoff you need Mexican this
is despite his own people telling him
that using technology instead of a wall
would be cheaper and more efficient and
he said if I wanted cheaper and more
efficient let the Mexicans in
but you know people are saying why now
why now why suddenly now troops at the
border well for the same reason
everything happens in this country now
because the president states saw
something on fox news they were showing
some fear porn about about a caravan did
you hear that a caravan is coming up
from Central America migrants through
heading north through Mexico that's why
now because he watches Fox News all day
if he watched The Price is Right
we'd be sending troops to San Francisco
to confront right Cerrone
I wonder this stock market is going up
and down every day and tanking and then
coming back and going back down because
no one knows what the [ __ ] is happening
anymore we're building a wall or maybe
not having a trade war with China or
maybe not we're getting out of Syria or
maybe not yeah the president this
president who was constantly said all
the time never tell the enemy what
you're doing that's stupid this week
announced were pulling out of Syria well
come on we're gonna need those troops
with the upcoming invasion of Amazon my
Toki's got a lot of ideas yeah he's got
a big feud with oh he hates @mr he has
mad at Amazon he says Amazon is using
the post office as a delivery system
the mail is not for Amazon to use the
mail is for coupons I don't want it ads
for things I'll never buy that I throw
away immediately that's what opposed
open
he hates China for making everything we
buy he hates Amazon for delivering it he
hates Mexico for dusting it no he's
turned to a loved Amazon back when they
delivered Milania for two-day free
shipping
oh no that's on support' melodia come on
for MOA she have to listen everyday to
all this stormy Daniels news here's what
I want to know how come stormy got paid
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
shutup and Melania is the one who won't
talk talk Milania speak your truth girl
be unfettered like your husband he's
unfettered now he's throwing the script
he's turning it up to eleven he's off
the chain people are so excited on the
right this week did you see this
yesterday it was he literally literally
threw away the script he was in West
Virginia supposed to be talking about
taxes this is what he did this is what
his prepared remarks you know this was
gonna be my remarks it would have taken
about two minutes but that is so rude
I mean Fox and Friends worked hard on
that
boring who needs policy extra to pull
information out of when I have an ass
oh but that's just that's just when the
fun started when he threw the paper
their biggest then he was free to riff
unfettered so he started to go over his
greatest hits did you see this talking
again about how millions voted illegally
in 2016 that's right Donald if it
weren't for fraud you'd have won
California EUR is popular out here as
bumper-to-bumper traffic caused by a
mudslide caused by fracking
[Applause]
he said his polling is almost at 60% his
approval rate
60% this is what he said Cody said a
poll just came out from Rasmussen that's
the conservative group but okay polka me
from Rasmus it's now 51 they say but
it's 51 but you gotta add seven or eight
to that you know like you do with your
penis